[Music]
I'm the one
you can identify as anything so you're
saying I shouldn't use any words you can
use whatever whatever you want okay guys
let's uh uh if you're here I I I uh
Anthony we're live buddy so if if you're
uh if you guys were here the last five
minutes you would have really enjoyed
what just happened here last five
minutes so this is almost called a blind
date because Anthony it's fair to say
you know nothing about our podcast not
true on the plane I listened to a couple
of the last few what did you listen to
which one did you like I listened to uh
a little bit of Jeffrey tuben and I
couldn't I trouble plowing through the
11 minute question that you started with
so I didn't I didn't hang around for
what he had to say I listened to last
week some guy named Reuben Dave Rubin
Dave Rubin oh yeah it was uh yeah yeah
he's a he's a hockey player very very
good hockey player actually great
basketball from uh uh L.A you played
hockey in a small little league with his
friends
he played real hockey second cousin to
Messier but I mean he's related some
some a little bit with uh Stephen cousin
to Messier yeah did he do rub a
candidate well okay well I listened to
him that was interesting listen to this
off the wall take on RFK which I thought
was hilarious but um but let's do a few
you guys do a great job here it's a
great I'm I'm thrilled to be here
because I'm new I'm relatively new to
Media yeah the business and so I wanted
to see what this model was all about so
so for the audience who doesn't know who
Anthony Weiner is I want to kind of give
a an intro because your show you got a
show going on right now called the
Middle with Anthony Weiner and it was a
time that everybody and anybody but give
me a little bit more give it a little
more oxygen I'm on 77 WABC radio in New
York 50 000 Watts Clear Channel powerful
AM radio but a very different model than
this we just give it to us again you're
in 77 markets no no 770. you see so this
is am terrestrial radio which might be
mysterious to some of your audience like
it's still old school terrestrial radio
it is the iconic wabc's the iconic radio
station been around for about 100 years
it's gone through a lot of different
things and recently a guy named John
katzmatitis you know that name at all no
he is start out in supermarkets in New
York then went into oil and now he's a
billionaire and so he bought the station
off the scrap Heap and but it's
terrestrial radio it's not it's
old-fashioned over the air and people
stream it and everything else but the
podcast part of it is an offshoot we
have it but it's really old-fashioned
recalls and you know calls and that kind
of thing so we do that and then also we
have like some podcast stuff I gotta
tell you man I I uh remember every other
a second we turned on the TV was a story
about you every day you were on it was
mathematically impossible a long time
ago long time ago but the audience who
doesn't know needs to kind of know so
let me kind of properly introduce you
Anthony David weiner uh is an American
former politician who served at the as
the U.S representative for New York's
ninth Congressional District from 1999
to his resignation in 2011 a member of
the democratic party consistently carry
the district with at least 60 percent of
the vote uh weiner resigned from
Congress June of 2011 after it was
revealed uh he sent sexually suggestive
photos of himself to different women a
two-time candidate for mayor of New York
City weiner finished second in
Democratic Primary in 2005. a lot of
people wanted you to actually become the
mayor and it was a super close ran again
in 2013 placed fifth in Democratic
Primary in 2017 you pleaded guilty for
transferring obscene material to a minor
and was sentenced to 21 months in prison
he was also required to permanently
register as a sex offender weiner began
serving his federal prison sentence the
Simeon was released in 2019 and now you
have a radio show with uh uh the Middle
with Anthony Weiner and it's available
on iTunes you can follow him on Twitter
which is what rep weiner if I'm saying
it correctly and you also got a YouTube
channel called ask Anthony Weiner we can
put all that stuff up yeah that's kind
of dated that stuff so I got to tell you
I watched your uh uh documentary last
night at midnight
a few things you're very weird I mean
that's very obvious you're a very weird
interesting guy but I'm gonna tell you
one thing defined adjective we're just
getting to know each other they're
already calling me weird we haven't we
barely know each other I I think the the
opportunity to get to know each other
was lost 10 minutes ago but the the idea
when I was watching the documentary I do
want to give you a compliment here's
what the compliment is
I can't believe
how relentless
you are as a campaigner I remember
reading a book called 40 Laws of Power
and when Lyndon Johnson was campaigning
the stories about what he did how
Relentless he was morning night driving
walking knocking on the doors of Love or
hate LBJ a lot of people you know can't
stand the guy for many different reasons
who were JFK guys
but they busted their ass so if you're
asking me about how I really felt about
you uh from the uh non-opinian side
you're a badass campaigner there's no
question about that you work your ass
off you want to show can't by the way
something a lot of people are now doing
today some people on the Republicans
side are now doing today I don't know if
that's right though I think that the
thing that many Americans don't realize
about the political system is that when
you
if you're going to get look some guys
have a ton of money you know who
basically can just buy advertising but
most elections are not waged on TV or
radio when they start like most
Congressional races you've got to go out
there and hustle you got to knock on
doors and if you wanna the great thing
about our democracy is the great
equalizer is the ability everyone has
700 000 members of people in their
District but if you're running for a
city council or mayor or a state senate
race
you can get up in the morning and just
hustle more than the other guy and just
like every other business in life I
would argue that gives you it's not the
equalizer is an exaggeration because
obviously you have a bunch of money
you're gonna or if you have a famous
name but that kind of thing that might
have been seen and I didn't see the
documentary but the portrayal that a lot
of us see on the documentary you don't
see it we're doing my own it's about me
I live that I didn't you didn't watch
you haven't seen the doctor what was the
reason you didn't want to watch it
a couple of reasons one is that I didn't
I wanted to have the ability to income
moments like this to say I hadn't seen
it I'm serious marketing reasons I guess
that's one way like I just didn't I had
no real interest in reliving something
that I had lived so intimately and that
still had a lot of wounds to it and then
there are processy things that I don't
know if you care about the guy who made
it was a former staffer of mine
and um he put my wife in it without a
consent
and he did it because he knew that her
boss was running for president we
wouldn't she wasn't going to sue him and
so I thought it was a really
dishonorable thing to do and so I
wouldn't I held a grudge a little bit so
but um but they're getting back to the
point Patrick that that I think that one
of the things that a good documentary
shows is something that people don't see
at first blush and if it portrayed the
idea that a good a good politician or
any politician can level the point when
I ran for City Council in New York City
I didn't have any country club
connections to go to I didn't have a
bunch of money a middle class kid my mom
was a school teacher but I got up every
morning at 5 30. and I stood at the
Subways until nine and then I went to
the supermarkets and walked the aisles
and then I knocked on doors and the high
rises and and I was able to to win by a
couple hundred votes and that was the
path that I that I took but I think a
lot of politicians people the
politicians that people know from their
own neighborhoods probably started out
that way so so where's the disagreement
you said I disagree that I was saying
you busted your ass no I'm saying um is
it that unusual that it I'm just saying
I think it's very unusual I I think a
lot of guys uh think money is enough we
saw that in a lot of different places
even today uh RFK I don't know how you
feel about RFK you know if you would
have said six months ago RFK is going to
give this much attention or vivec is
going to give this much attention these
guys are out working pretty much every
one of their competitors the way their
uh campaigning and I'll just a direct
question to you what do you think about
what rfk's been doing
he's been getting a lot of attention on
podcasts from a lot of middle-aged white
guys who are fascinated with him he's
getting pumped up by Republicans who
seem as a troublemaker and he's getting
in more and more trouble the the higher
what do they say the higher the monkey
climbs the more you can see his ass
every time he turns around he's getting
in deeper and deeper and he's and
whatever mission that he had is gonna is
ending in men failures so would you say
Silicon Valley is Republican or Democrat
most of Silicon Valley money well I did
I don't know what his money situation is
and its almost doesn't matter I mean
look I did a podcast about him and
Christy two people who were apparently
running to help the other party that
they claim to be trying to run and help
yeah so but it's irrelevant every every
campaign season we have the same thing
and it's particularly acute now that we
are kind of bored with who we have and
so the media loves to pump oxygen into
people who probably don't deserve it in
Kennedy it's just I mean look it's
Kennedy the name Kennedy the you don't
like them you don't like I don't I don't
know him remember personally I mean I
think he's
he's up he's selling books pretty clear
to me that's all he's doing you think
he's selling books okay I mean if you
use something let me know your monkey
climbs the more you see his ass
I'm getting the vibe you're not a fan is
that well I wouldn't
look the guy he's
he's a he's a conspiracy charlatan I I
run I do a show where I try to take
people steps back and I find that Venn
diagram where people who are interested
in both sides of the aisle but they want
to have a conversation based on
substance and based on facts he's not
doing that he's a conspiracy theorist
I'm they I don't hold them in higher
Reasons I'm very substantive of other
things he's saying about guns drugs
a lot of the crypto Community is an
advocate of him which is which is which
is ironic for a guy who claimed who
claims to be an echo-war
environmentalist he's changed his tune
on that look he's doing what one common
thread you can find whatever is making
your money whatever's getting attention
is what he's doing so CR so so he was an
environmentalist now cryptocurrency is
where he's deriving some of his money so
suddenly he's not so concerned about the
environment he's he's he he this it's
clear to me that this that this
attention grab around around
anti-vaxxing is a money grab you can go
there they're featuring now on Amazon
especially for the election a new box
set of all of his books or whatever it
is it's a MoneyGram when I look at why
candidates are running there's usually a
couple things one they're running
because they really think they're going
to win another group of people are
running because they're running for
something else like you know I think the
candidates in South Carolina are
probably running for vice president then
there are candidates who are running for
the next time it seems like DeSantis is
probably doing that and then there are
people who just want to get their name
out there for some vague money making or
Prestige or or career sense and that's
what I believe RFK is so let me read
this article to you so Silicon Valley
money men are buzzing about RFK this is
a Wall Street Journal story
prominent figures in Silicon Valley such
as Jack Dorsey shamat David Sachs are
expressing support for rfk's uh
presidential campaign drawn to his
willingness to challenge the status quo
Dorsey recently voiced his backing
stating the more people here from RFK
the more they agree with our view that
he should be part of the debate going
forward Kennedy's engagement with the
Tech Community including appearances on
podcasts and discussions on platforms
like Twitter spaces has resonated with
some tech leaders who values
anti-establishment stance shamat Express
have always been anti-establishment the
idea of tearing down all these
institutions of power gives me Glee so
to get the attentions of guys in Silicon
Valley that don't necessarily consider
like ourselves why do I care about those
guys maybe you should
I didn't ask if I should I said why
should I care that that's the question
why should they care about what you say
though fair enough I'm not asking I'm
not I'm not saying that they should but
that's this is a podcast so we're
bringing up the story to
you said the you know RFK is getting a
lot of Republican money he's not he's
getting Democratic I didn't say that
yeah you said he's getting a lot of
Republican money that have interesting
people who are propping him up as a
troublemaker yeah yeah you said
Republicans specifically but yeah he's
got his Republican support that's where
his growth is supporting he said four
percent among Democrats that's where
your theory last week about he's going
to be a third party like you can just
invent the party out of whole cloth and
that he's going to be a troublemaker for
Democrats he's the best thing could
possibly have you do follow the podcast
okay so so so who do you like Anthony
who do you like which of these guys do
you like I gotta tell you are you like a
die-hard Biden guy are you a uh I think
we we have something that I I call and
this is a trademark so don't see what I
call it the backup quarterback syndrome
in politics that we always think the guy
who's on the sideline is going to be the
better candidate the better player and
so this time time of the cycle it's who
else is out there it doesn't matter who
else is out there it's going to be Biden
and Trump so and and that choice is
crystal clear for me so who do I want
who do I think would be better I don't
know the guy who's in the job is doing a
pretty good job at the job he's wildly
unpopular but then again so is everybody
everyone's unpopular now so I mean I'm
I'm gonna vote for Joe Biden you're
going to vote for Donald Trump and We're
Off to the Races but I don't think it
matters I mean I'd like I mean I I
listen to these guys none of them seem
particularly interesting to me because
they're not terribly interested in doing
anything to depart from the Orthodoxy of
their candidate I mean I you know I
don't know if that's on the screen but
Cornell West is who I'm doing my show
about this Saturday
I mean that's a problem a green Party
candidate cost Hillary Clinton the
election in 2016 and Cornell West is
could conceivably do that again
I'm a Green Party candidate oh yes yes
but he's a much better known figure than
Jill Stein and he he's a better
attention getter and I think he's a
better speaker so he's the potential to
be the Perot effect a viable candidate
that gets just enough for that because
elections go down to the nine points in
the middle so yeah but I would agree
with that but it pro is an open question
I think historically you can look it's a
weird dynamic traditionally speaking a
third party would would harm the
incumbent right that's the that's the
common sense view of it but in that case
it was a very weird dynamical was going
on because Clinton was doing a change
election and Perot was to change his
freaking thing out am I left curse in
the show go for it it's the changes
freaking thing out there was Ross Pro so
I I know there's been a lot of talk that
Perot cost Bush the election I know Bush
thought that but I'm not sure the math
holds up on that but in terms of Cornell
West it's clear every single one of a
lefty green you know candidate
African-American who talks about you
know the Democratic party not doing
enough for African-Americans that's two
points in Wisconsin right there right
well two points probably high but a
point and a half of Wisconsin where the
margin last time was only a point and a
half so Aaron a question for you in
regards to campaigning mayor uh which is
a city then you have the state versus
you got Nation like the census Congress
Governor how different is it campaigning
uh you know City Congress district
versus Governor versus president well
mayor of New York City is a whole
different creature right I mean you're
campaigning for mayor the city of New
York
you're attracting national attention
because first what's an off-year
election it's not held at the same time
so it's a really Barren time on the
political calendar but in in essence
it's the same thing it is thrust and
Parry around issues what people care
about
identifying what it is you're trying to
say in a very short concise thing the
stuff I find that I found and again you
you've taken a run of me for not
watching the the show when you out but
the stuff you do around marketing is
interesting to me one of the reasons I
wanted to come here is kind of see the
marketing side of this so there is a
marketing and a notion of like figuring
out what works and what doesn't but in a
broad sense presidential candidates are
very different
things than anything else in politics
because you're running this weird
bifurcated campaign of a national
campaign and this weird state-by-state
thing where you can be campaigning in
Iowa talking about completely different
issues than you're talking about when
you go to New Hampshire or South
Carolina that doesn't happen I mean some
degree you know you go
Upstate in New York or Tallahassee
compared to Miami you get a little bit
of that when you run as a governor but
you really get it as that's why I think
States like New York Florida California
a governor who says look I know from
dealing with different communities I
know with different geographies
different economic imperatives that
makes me ready to be president which is
why Americans choose
Governors so often to be president
um you said earlier we you know we're
talking about RFK you're like well it's
just a money grab he's trying to get
money he's trying to sell books he's
trying to do this did you read his
faulty book or no oh God no you haven't
read it did I read The Foundry book no I
didn't I didn't I don't why not I don't
I it's much easier just to to read other
people who who debunk crazy conspiracy
theories I don't have to read The
Conspiracy Theory
so so what was conspiracy theory about I
am I am I'm not gonna if your listeners
want to go and do their own research on
it I'm not going to sit here and be
fouchy versus versus Kennedy on a
conspiracy I mean I just don't have any
interest in that in doing what and doing
the construction and being one side of a
of a conspiracy theorist like debunking
a conspiracy theorist you can get other
people on for that you get all kinds of
people who are real experts in the stuff
to do that online so what's your show
about
so the thesis is it's a very
conservative radio station you guys have
a pretty conservative audience here I I
surmise probably center right I would
assume a very very capitalist
entrepreneurial free thinkers pretty
conservative
I love I my my boss the owner of my
station says we're center right I'm like
boss I'm the only thing that's not a
hard ride on the entire station so we're
not center right we're pretty right but
I believe in the idea I represent a
fairly conservative District by the
standards of New York Archie Bunker's
house was in my district that's in what
city by the way New York City
in New York City that was your District
what area oh uh the the outer boroughs
of queens and Brooklyn working class
areas not the fancy high-rises the
places where as I mentioned Archie
Bunker from um
uh All in the Family All in the Family
yeah
very conservative places I lost 80 20
for example you know when I left
Congress when I told Nancy Pelosi you
want me out I want to warn you this is
going to be a republican seat when I
leave it was
so and and I prosecuted that job of with
the argument being that we that we all
have our partisanship even more so now
than when I was in office but we I think
there's a healthy group of people in the
in the Venn diagram of Democrat and
Republican who don't want one hand
clapping who want to hear what the other
side has to say who want to engage in
some kind of a conversation about it it
doesn't seem that way in American Media
today I will admit that that most of the
money is on one side or the other one
silo or the other I am trying out the
theory that if I try to be a Democrat a
well-known famous
you know fired up green establishment
type of a Democrat like well you say
establishment and I did run against the
establishment every time I ran you are a
pretty establishment buddy nobody gets I
mean you're as establishment as a guest
well I don't know when I was in Congress
I was causing all kinds of headaches I
remember because I was advocating for
left on on on on on on health care I was
advocating right on Israel and law
enforcement you can put establishment
all I know is from establishment is most
establishments in
um in in my district in New York City
and in Washington didn't like me and
were happy when I was out so that's all
I can say about the establishment but
let me just finish my thoughts real
quick with the establishment I mean
you're very closely linked with the
clintons whether you're Bush Clinton
that's his establishment as it gets it's
not not fair I guess it I I guess I'm
I'm uh I was married to her Deputy
deputy chief staff at the state
department
um but remember something you know Bill
Clinton was not an establishment guy
when he started right he came frankly
ran against the establishment when a lot
of people thought it wasn't a smart time
to run in 92 Etc but all of that being
said but then he became the
establishment when you become the
president you become the establishment
Donald Trump is like the outside guy
he's the president the guy was he's now
very deaf far far from establishing he
was not establishment but once you're
saying that he wasn't established I'm
just responding to the idea that people
run when they're not the establishment
but once you become the institution of
the presence you become the assistant
the fine establishment what is
establishment to you
well maybe we should both do it since it
was in your question but I guess
establishment is the organizations and
institutions of politics and whether
they like you or don't like you
okay whether you pose a threat to them
or not a threat to them I can only
assume given their eagerness to get rid
of me
and I I can attest to this that I don't
consider myself a sign but I also don't
consider it such a pejorative if by
establishment you mean someone who like
you used it that got elected president
that got elected Congress a whole bunch
of times when is a middle class kid who
like with the name Anthony Weiner uh
okay yes I was a member of the United
States House of Representatives a job
that is in the Constitution of the
United States that is by definition the
established you know you know you know
uh what
um has happened last few years it's a
little weird that you said I don't want
to talk about it Rob can you pull up the
article that just came out paragraph 19
New York Times on the amount of covet
bets that they reported uh and and this
this word that the CIA came up with
called conspiracy theory that a lot of
people like to throw around hey this is
a conspiracy and that there's some well
the history of it goes back but CI was
one of the ones that really took it to a
whole different level if you read this
article here or go to the part where
it's okay the far left who you're
reading from the the the this is the New
York Times that's the Breitbart well we
can go to the New York Times article if
you want to so the far left New York
Times quietly admits this week that
that's
from coronavirus were over counted by 30
percent uh G another right-wing
conspiracy theory theory is proven true
and by the way can you go to the
paragraph where it's actually written uh
the way it is it's on a a different
article I think that launched
uh go to exaggeration
Milestone Search the word exaggeration
if you can There You Go the official
number
uh okay so uh covert also be clear has
not Fallen to zero that uh eighty
percent the official number is probably
an exaggeration because it includes some
people who had virus when they died even
though it was not underlying it was not
the underlying cause of death like my
father other CDC data suggests sorry for
your loss suggest that almost one-third
of official recent covert vets have
fallen into this category that is a big
number so when we're sitting around
every day we're watching the news and
everybody is panicking people's lives
are being stopped keeps kids are now
going people are dying a million people
are dying yeah a million people are
dying but you're saying to do what stop
everything you're saying to force
everything I'm just saying you you were
you were you were taking that as a way
to minimize the chat the and I am taking
the other position that I don't think
you minimize a million people I don't
think anybody minimize it I think the
language sound pretty minimizing do you
see the part about a third is that a
conspiracy theory
the one-third is is a hyperlink we can
probably go look and see what that is
that sounds like it makes a lot of sense
to me well now it does so this is why
America the difference what what point
are you making here my brother oh you
were about to say what difference does
it make a legendary quote used by
somebody else well no what difference
does it make to your point you're saying
this is not a cons this is a conspiracy
but no no you're saying when I said have
you read the book I said why would you
read the book that's all conspiracy
theories no this is he didn't say this
he had hit conspiracy theories which you
know what he said about because I
explained this earlier to your question
I I read the reviews of the book and the
debunking you read the reviews got it so
so kind of like as a if I'm in a office
and I have to go through a certain new
legislation that's coming up I just wait
to see what New York Times
a lot of people tune into your program
to find out about other things in the
news and get a perspective on it to draw
conclusions because they trust you isn't
that true right so I have sources that I
trust this is not such a novel idea but
I would read the other side sites books
you would read every book on both sides
of everyone if it's one of the biggest
crisis we experience over a three-year
period yeah guys guys if I have anyone
within the sound of my voice can read
the what [__] that guy is spewing
but I I'm not going to have you enough
by the way you're making the DeSantis
mistake now any guys say that again the
DeSantis mistake is but it's the
Churchill effective believing that that
what was a giant issue two years ago
that animates people is still a giant
issue that Adam is a problem with this
you think that you think DeSantis is
still making that no I think DeSantis is
running a campaign based on things are
no longer so Anthony well that's the
reason that he's relevant that's kind of
like
the whole reason that he's on the
Forefront of the campaign excuse me how
do you define Forefront he's getting
crushed he's in second place right now
he's getting he's trailing by 40 points
yeah you're right but but I'm explaining
I'm first off I'm changing the subject
but I'm also explaining I'm explaining
the the phenomenon that he experienced
Rudy Giuliani the Winston Churchill that
you can be amazingly good in your mind
and for your voter's mind in a certain
issue but once that issue recedes the
salience of that and the importance of
that issue recedes as well that's the
mistake that Santa's making and and by
the way with all due respect this is why
people don't like you and trust you this
is why America doesn't trust the
establishment and and the one thing I
watch am I going to be the harbinger The
Establishment in this conversation no no
you're part of it because the American
people okay the American people people
who follow the guidelines not the people
that didn't follow the guidelines the
people that took the covet vaccine the
people that followed the non-essential
the people that didn't go to work the
people that kept their kids from going
to school and they said the experts are
telling me this you dramatically change
my my life and now you're saying what
difference does it mean no I didn't say
that no no no no no I said what
differences who cares what's behind us
so the factors don't talk about it we
have some time here so let's let's go
back for a moment you were pointing to a
reference in there and talking about a
conspiracy theory and whether it was
reduced from less than I thought you
called it a conspiracy theory I did not
you're claiming it's a conspiracy theory
you are debunking it by going to a clip
and you pointing to the 100 times and I
said what difference does it make to the
argument you were making I didn't
understand because you said it's been
two or three years but people don't care
anymore that's what you're trying to say
I was making you you have it you're
giving me Whiplash no I was making an
argument why DeSantis is struggling in
the polls in an effort to change the
subject quite frankly struggling in the
like move thank you struggling in the
polls is because he is pursuing this
line I I think that's that's the
furthest reason why he's not doing well
in the polls okay successfully you
change the subject all right why do you
think why he's not succeeding in the
polls yeah I mean I heard you listen
last week when Rob said when Rob said
Anthony Weiner you know for example on
the show here Saturday we'll have Chris
Cuomo here okay on a podcast he's flying
just to do the podcast and he flies back
me too uh we've had uh uh tonight will
be Dave Smith tomorrow's Ice Cube we've
interviewed people from Left Right
Center everybody what are some examples
of left uh Kyle Kolinski Sam Cedar uh
Jenkins coming back Andrew Yang David I
can give you a bunch of names who's
David pack you should look him up you
should start doing a little research I
don't think you'll read enough I should
but the part I would say too is the
following
the reason this is exactly the reason
why people have a hard time believing
what guys like you are saying rob we
don't even put it into other people's
perceptions let me ask you a question
about this let me ask you a question
about the sentence let me answer the
question about the centers to be fair
the reason why uh you may say well you
know what this is why this sentence is
not doing well well this is why Trump is
doing well because people want to know
what the hell happened during covet well
this is why Vivek is doing well so your
argument was preceded in every poll
the scientist isn't campaigning the
sentence is not going out there descent
is not talking enough
painting like a [__] is what he's doing
he's not he's he's when you want to take
out the king you've got to mean it he
doesn't he's running for four years from
now but it's all fine but I'm just
saying I was making a point about how
sometimes candidates fall in love with
the narrative about themselves their
polling looks amazing and then the world
around them changes and suddenly an
issue that was so important when Rudy
Giuliani left and he and he's also on 77
WABC talk radio the most powerful
station in the nation when he left in
2001 he was the least popular mayor in
New York City's history
he was worse than de Blasio when when he
left now September 11th came and changed
that overnight but putting that aside
for a moment part of the reason is he
didn't get no one was saying oh my God
murders used to be 2 000 and now they're
500. no one said it because it had
receded his initially they moved on to
other things they wanted someone to be
less divisive they wanted different
things there's something called
accountability and American people
wanted yeah okay and you don't because
you're a politician you're not somebody
that's you're almost someone um it's
quite the opposite my friend I'm trying
to give you a person you do punditry on
this show I've listened to it I'm doing
some punditry about why DeSantis is not
doing well you and I can disagree we're
both speculating but you I'm I'm open to
your speculation but saying that I'm
wrong is probably not the right way oh
when it comes down to the way he's
campaigning we're on the same page that
you're not going to get a debate here
about campaigning but to argue the fact
that for example I'll give you an idea
uh
what is the one conspiracy people from
all sides are most obsessed with and
have been obsessed with for now
60 years okay all right it happened on
November 22nd 63 the six year
anniversary is coming up do you think we
should know who killed uh who
assassinated John or do you think it
doesn't matter
I I bumped I'm curious doesn't affect my
life very much and probably a lot of
your younger listeners probably don't
care that much but it doesn't affect my
life that much but sure I want to find I
want to find out where the UF UFOs and
how important is it to know about it how
important is it for us to know similar
to how important it is for me to put
food on the table how important is to
have a good school system I'm important
is to be able to get to work how
important is to be able to come in the
Parkland here and not have floods not
very okay so curiosity with the flood
thing Anthony it's freaking raining now
my thing is my thing I'm I'm at the at
the end of the day um I look around I'm
always like thinking like a mayoral
candidate so when I see a community
service or a landlord is not doing their
job or or a a function of how government
works in different places I take notice
of it how how much time have you spent
in South Florida not a lot the whole
freaking place is flooded why
uh we're like five feet above ground is
it rain are you troubled by that and it
floods yeah you've got to look at the
floods in this country let's stay on
this topic okay I want to stay on this
topic the last thing I'm concerned about
right now is flooding
that's a fascinating dichotomy the last
few consider is flooding but you now
want to Pivot to the JFK assassination
that's more important I think for a lot
of people in this country this summer
they would probably say flooding is a
little bit more important than the jfks
and not only that we have to worry
because the world is coming to an end
due to climate change in 12 years that's
something that we have to remember
it's happened every time
it's a bad time to be taking a run a
climate change this particular summer
man yeah so going back to it you don't
think it's an important issue for us to
know who killed the JFK like yeah I
don't care would you put in your top 20.
no way if you want to sit down wait a
minute in what context though in the
context of you the way you put it is an
important issue in the context of me
voting for establishment people 100 I
would in the context of me seeing CIA
has way too much power 100 percent
how much power doj has 100 percent
100 let me just make this point in the
comment section I bet you people can do
20 easily before they get to this about
their own lives about their concern
about the future
it's about voting it's about voting
those two things are synonymous with all
due respects I think you missed his
entire point it's it's
it's a metaphor for really The
Establishment and what's going on with
that I get it but aren't you concerned
about that agency can you can you do me
a favor the mistrust that people have
for the CI the FBI I know but the JFK
assassination doesn't rise Steven the
top 20 and that's it part of that bigger
category and I said at the beginning I
said it's a thing it's not a very
important thing right and you sound like
somebody and I want to play this clip to
see if this is somebody you look up to
or not Rob can you please play this for
me if you could I'm going to text it
over to you this is what it sounds like
okay if you want to play it this is what
it is I'm sorry go ahead yeah totally
get it Aaron go ahead and play this
uh
Rob do you have it I just texted it to
you if you can pull it out just give me
one second yeah for I think
um is it a voice I recognition it's it's
oh you're going to recognize a little
you definitely have to recognize so it's
uh uh uh it's the issue with two
communities okay if you look at this
here famous line on what she said okay
go ahead and play this
Americans was it because of a protest or
was it because of guys out for a walk
one night who decided they'd go kill
some Americans what difference at this
point does it make you agree with that
she kicked ass in the bank out of here
you guys watch that you'll remind me of
her you remind me of her they say yeah
and so so by the way what do you think
about the clintons what do you think
about the clintons
arguably she arguably and let's see if
you can come up with a name who who
exceeds this the most qualified person
ever to run for president United States
a former Senator former Secretary of
State a former first lady
I mean would have been an amazing
president would have done a better job
in virtually every every way
um and why do you think she didn't
become one
oh god
um from a 2016 perspective like going
back and rehashing the the yeah I mean
you were in it so why do you think she
didn't I wasn't I wasn't in it oh my
wife was in it so you're married to the
woman that was the right-hand person to
her so you're interested actually we
were separated at the time the answer is
no and I was in rehab for the important
part of the campaign so no I wasn't very
I wasn't connected with that campaign at
all in any way
um in retrospect probably because the
corrupt head of the FBI put the finger
on the scale for Donald Trump
so you're blaming Comey
well if you want to have one hot take
you know there's a lot of different
things that went into that the Electoral
College is a [__] show and you know
we're stuck with it but it is what it is
she got way more votes than the other
guy got but you know as you can argue
that Jill Stein Jill Stein got two two
percent of Wisconsin and Hillary lost by
by uh by less than a percent Jill Stein
got about 1.8 percent in um in in in in
in uh in Pennsylvania so yeah I mean
there there are lots of things I mean
2016 is a long time ago now but yeah how
much of it you think it was uh with
Russian collusion and Russia being
involved and Trump involved with Russia
and all that stuff I believe I believe
Donald Trump's um intelligence officials
I believe them when when they said that
that the Russians attacked us for the
purpose of helping Donald Trump that's
Donald Trump's own people said it I
believe him what do you think about what
Durham said oh Durham the prosecutor
that didn't prosecute anyone what did
Durham say we already had we already had
we we had the Mueller report we already
had the the Inspector General support in
2019 we got this guy who said he was
going to going to arrest the people to
get to the bottom of it he did nothing
all he basically said was that some type
of a some type of a uh of a process the
FBI followed should have been a
different process that they followed
Durham was uh are you still talking
about Durham I'm surprised you guys
aren't like you are discarding you are
you are you are exactly the reason why
people can't my dude you keep you keep
putting it in the third person if you
want to say something to me say you
believe it don't say other people
clearly some people a lot of people
clearly if I'm saying that I'm taking
ownership of that statement but you're
exactly the reason better why people
don't trust like no I disagree with you
and you're not used to having people
decisions
if you want me to agree with you I can
do that I have watched enough zero
desire for you to
let me finish my thought if you want me
to come on here and do the hmm
yeah well maybe if I believe something
I'm gonna say it and I and and I I'm and
I'm doing it and I'm not just using this
phrase I'm trying to be respectful to
the notion here if we're having a
conversation you say what is Durham and
I tore the shreds out of Durham I'm
gonna keep doing it if you want me to
Nerf it for you I will I should totally
so the three and a half years of MSNBC
mainstream media talking about Russia
Russia Russia Russia Russia was all true
wait I don't you can't say three and a
half years Russia Russia I don't like
MSNBC either yeah it bores me to tears
okay so so but but it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't MSNBC saying this thing it was
Donald Trump's National Security ship
coming out saying we have Accu you have
absolute evidence that the Trump
Administration was colluding with Russia
and we're like oh wait a minute maybe he
was they're meeting in their meeting in
in in in in in Suites in Trump Tower
with literal Russian agents according to
wait for it the Trump Administration
told us this why this is not in dispute
anymore it is Donald Trump's career
advisor Donald Trump CIA Donald Trump's
FBI Donald Trump's people came out and
then a bipartisan report in the United
States Senate said the same thing and
then an inspector General's report said
this exact same thing what do you mean
MSNBC said it the only people not saying
are the people who aren't paying
attention at this point but it's not the
end look it's not the end of the lord we
go on we were attacked by a country they
succeeded now we're gonna now we're
gonna try to make it better that's why
in 2020 when there was more talk about
attack acts that's why we some we over
calibrate in the other direction with
Hunter Biden we are a flawed country but
we should try to get better each time we
do this and if we get attacked one time
what service do we do by denying it why
do we do service then I what denying
that the Russians attacked us well we
know they did okay so so why why are you
denying what happened during covid when
you're saying ah just listen it's behind
us
all right all right
you want to do covert yourself I don't
want to go with me all right let's try I
mean I'm not the best person so many
better people get on to do perfect yeah
let's go I believe a million people
dying is a big deal I believe Donald
Trump saying you should drink bleach is
a dumb idea I believe he lost the
election because of it we have
accountability and now we're doing
better right and again going back to it
when we talked RFK this is not about
covet I don't have any desire to talk
about covet right now when we talked RFK
I ask you did you read the book and he
said why would I read a conspiracy
theory book then you said well it's
behind us this is the same exact mistake
said that he pointed out that one fact
and said it was one-third and someone
called it a conspiracy theory and it was
one-third I stipulate to the idea that
it was one-third so it's a million
people we don't and and there you go I
stipulate to that but I didn't read the
book and I don't need to read the book
and you put a clip on from Breitbart and
claimed it was the New York Times then
we put the New York Times into much more
nuanced explanation and nuances where I
think we should live wait these are
complicated things what nuanced they
quoted something
bring the clip back up because you know
English is my fifth language but I just
want to read this again to make it very
clear this can't be good radio but go
ahead yeah this can't be well you're on
a radio station that most your listeners
are a week away from dying so I don't
know how many people yeah and being
disrespectful is not what I do I respect
them and honor it's your show you know I
respect them and unwrap this up
you know when when Rob told me Pat
Anthony Weiner agreed to do this podcast
I said okay
um
I said I gotta respect that the fact
that he's at least coming down there's a
lot of people right now we're about to
do a uh Town Hall I believe we're doing
a town hall here with Vivek in two weeks
we're doing a town hall where pretty
much every candidate's been invited to
do a town hall
uh and and audience will be able to ask
questions I respect anybody that's
willing to go and sit down for example
Newsome went to Hannity and sat down
with Hannity okay
yeah you got the santis which by the way
was very interesting your last interview
with him a year ago when he asked you
question how much has changed with you
and have you changed since all this
stuff in your life and your answer was I
think so it's the audience decision to
judge that was kind of a weird answer
when you said that well if you wanna if
you first off instead of characterizing
it you want to play it for you if you
want to play it I mean if you want to
play it go ahead and play let's let's
play it and let's read it I'm not I mean
but if you want to go back I don't want
to go I'm kind of all over the map here
but go ahead I'll be glad to to go I
don't
but I got one last question
WABC radio in New York they are
exploring the Left Right divide and
major issues afflicting New York City
and Beyond one of the co-hosts is former
New York Congressman Anthony Weiner he
spent 18 months in confinement for
sexting with a 15 year old girl he was
released in 2019 he says he's ready to
answer tough questions about his own
life the challenges facing the country
he's joining now our friend Curtis Sliwa
with a new show their co-host the left
first of the right uh Anthony Weiner
thank you for being with us Curtis leawa
uh always good to see you my friend
I guess the first question that I have
is you pled guilty Anthony
to sending obscene materials to a young
girl 15 year old girl you went you pled
guilty you served jail time
have you changed are you a different
person
well
um I think so I don't think anyone can
go through that kind of experience and I
think this is probably true of people
who have been to other types of
adversity I don't think you go through
that type of experience and don't emerge
changed but Anthony wait a minute
that's an obscure answer I think so
either you know in your heart if you
changed or you know in your heart if you
didn't change
or do you can you assure people because
you're going to now try and draw on an
audience and they're going to want to
know if you've changed or not have you
changed
they they they can judge for themselves
I'm sorry
I said they can judge for themselves I'm
not out to persuade you or anyone else
that I've changed I mean I I'm doing a
radio show and people can call and ask
me questions we did one this past
Saturday where people had an opportunity
to call in and deposit we're correct
you said you want to react to it no
no I just you were characterizing
yourself let's let rather than you
characterize it was that pretty accurate
on characterizing it or was I lit off I
forgot I'd be honest I just want to make
sure I'm pretty accurate would it be
fair to say
you stand by that statement do you think
you have changed dude I didn't know
those allegations those are heinous
allegations have you changed
well we we have a nuanced relationship
with the notion of change in addiction
that we believe that you don't stop
being an addict that every day you've
got to take your medicine it's no
different than being an epileptic that
once you once you know you have the
disease you've got to take your
medication
15 year old girl a disease
well I I did all of these things under
the influence of an addiction that I
still have what is that addiction
um
I would I would carry on I've talked
about this a lot on the radio show
but
not it's a little bit of a hard pivot
here
I would carry on with dozens and dozens
and dozens and dozens of people
in something that I never met any of
them
and in those dozens and dozens of
interactions some of them would be
sexual some of them would not be sexual
some of them would be me giving advice
on how to change the you know a fuse in
your car
but that interaction that I was getting
into was stimulating something in me
that was addictive that was I couldn't
stop even after I had increasingly more
worse consequences I couldn't stop
um it uh it accelerated to the point
where I hit my bottom actually when I
went to prison was not when I had my
bottom it was before then I went to
rehab and I am in recovery today but
call it what you want I mean my brother
died in addict
I I mean programs for addiction around
this Behavior what were you addicted to
it's not really clear what was doing the
thing is it the
feedback is it uh the flirting is it uh
affirmation is it uh who who knows
process addictions like gambling and
whatever overspent like sometimes they
they unlike an uh people who deal with
alcohol or which I'm also you know not
doing
they're very easy put the cork in the
bottle we now bind everything this is
what it is that you're addicted to in
today's world the rooms that I'm in are
filled with people that it manifested a
lot of different ways people with
pornography people around
escorts people around different elements
of the of of the part of our brain that
stimulates that kind of stuff so you're
an attention addict are you drug
addicted I I mean the narcissist the
program well narcissist is a is a
diagnosis of a thing
I'm in a program for sex addicts
that has a really a wide range of bottom
lines the people in these rooms
um and we have a
we have a tradition not to talk about it
just like AAA has but doesn't do much
anymore but yeah I mean my my program of
recovery is related to sex addiction
are you talking like from a standpoint
of sex addiction or uh you hear the
phrase the minor attractive persons is
that is that what you're talking about I
didn't the court said I didn't have any
attraction to minors the the court case
we never had a trial yeah
um as no one gets trials there are no
trials anymore in this country we're
down to about two percent of cases go to
trial because of the penalties around
going to trial
I pled I accept responsibility I did my
time I have
um I understood the the that I
understood what the judge meant when she
said that no one's ever been sentenced
for this before but because you're a
public figure and we have to make an
example
I understand someone has to be the first
in these types of circumstances
all of that being said I don't think the
system is corrupt I don't think the fat
you know that I think there are things
that should be fixed in it but I I this
is this is the greatest country on Earth
we have a criminal justice system that
is the worst in the world except when
compared to every other one and I I know
that when you're a person of my
prominence
that that
um that there's an expectation that I'm
going to be sentenced for things that
someone else might not be do you think
you should have gone to jail no you're
not I should not go what were the exact
charges
so the exact as they said what I was I
pled to there was no they I didn't have
a chance to go to trial I didn't have a
chance for them to put proof on and I'm
you know that they didn't there was no
physical evidence there was no
no I should not have gone to no one's
ever gone to jail for this I mean we had
a former governor and prosecuted in the
same district that literally was using
money in transactions to hire sex
workers and things like that and he
wasn't prosecuted he resigned and you
know whatever he he left in disgrace my
disgrace and dishonor that I met with
and being in recovery and and trying to
get my life back I don't think people
should go to prison for what I did how
concerned are you that this is your
Everlasting Legacy
you know we have a saying what other
people think of me is none of my
business I I don't have a particular I
heard a conversation it was an
interesting one about Legacy that you
did with just for Jeffrey tuben so to
let you know that I was listening by the
way to be fair we actually liked the guy
Jeffrey Tubman and we laughed and had a
great time with the guy even though we
disagreed with many different things
yeah it sounded like he's he's a good
guy he sounded like his book was
interesting but but you asked this
question about Legacy and
I am not Terror you you I think part of
what led me into an addictive spiral was
being in in airports and having people
come up to me and want to take pictures
of me I was famous for being for
shouting at Hannity and beating the crap
out of uh out of Fox News guys and
jousting and fighting and whatever it is
the most famous thing I ever did in
Washington was having a loud exchange
over the 911 First Responders will
and that type of mania the type of like
well what do people think about me at
this oh I have
people love me but do they love me
enough do they love me the right way and
and so this notion of do I get do I get
do I get up every morning
look at my son sleeping in bed think
about the problems my city faces my
country faces think about the ways I can
be service to other addicts who are sick
and suffering and do I say well I wonder
what's going to happen my father died a
month ago do I wonder what people are
going to say at my I don't to be honest
with you that stuff that way of thinking
about things all I can do is today if
someone says to me do you want to get on
a plane and go down and do this
interesting podcast with these guys who
might not agree with you but but who
knows maybe someone will be watching
will say oh that's an interesting thing
let me tune into Anthony's show huh
that's an interesting take let me give
more oxygen to people who do that all I
can do is today take the next right step
and if I get too concerned about future
tripping about well what will this
people think about me so when when Sean
Hannity says to me have you changed or
are you better or have you improved and
I say I don't know and then I put some
meat on the bones and I say look that's
for other people to decide if they want
I'm not terribly concerned about that if
someone wants to ask me a specific
question like you've asked me today I'll
be glad to answer it but no I'm not
particularly concerned have you watched
sounds of freedom the movie I've read a
Dean I don't want to walk into the same
chap I've read about it what is it I've
read a lot of things about it what is it
about exactly it's a very popular movie
now it's you haven't watched sounds of
freedom I I haven't watched any movies
to be honest but no I don't uh do you
think uh uh you know the stats they
quote and sounds of Freedom which is as
a father of four you got one that's 11
about to be 12. I got an 11 97 and a
two-year-old so you know uh uh um the
mindset of a father where when once you
have a kid you're no longer in one place
you're always in two places if you got
one three places four places five places
so you're continuously everywhere
um
they quote the stats of 20 million new
child pornography pictures have been
uploaded on the internet the last 12
months I'd say five thousand percent
increase in the last uh five years
um the fact that it's a 150 billion
dollar industry per year pedophilia uh
uh human trafficking the fact that you
can sell cocaine once but you can sell a
five-year-old child five to ten times a
day for 10 years uh depending on what
the age of the kid is and that this is a
crisis that is happening with minors
around the world with what's going on
around the border right now where kids
are coming unaccompanied this is a real
issue do you see that as a top five
crisis in America today it's a it's a
huge problem I have to I I didn't know
that's what the movie was about it's a
huge problem but I'll go beyond that I
mean there is a multi I don't want to
get out of my skis and it's probably a
trillion dollar industry around
pornography of all types that is
completely I mean I see guys in these
rooms you know we have this this notion
of of the eighth and nine steps of
making amends
and these guys who who are addicted to
pornography and the idea that every time
they're watching pornography it's
probably a human traffic door if
someone's who's been exploited or
someone who's forced into these things
this is a this is a huge a huge problem
writ large I haven't seen the program
but it's it sounds as a father it sounds
it sounds hard you're not equivocating
porn with child sex trafficking well
what I'm saying is that that that I I'm
putting them in the same category I'm
putting them really I'm putting them in
the same place consensual sex well hold
on a second hold on versus child sexual
we have no idea we have no idea about
what consent people have given whether
whether they're if you don't believe
that porn is exploitive of people
then I mean you you and I have to have a
different understanding I'm not saying
that all of it is I'm not saying I
highly disagreeing I'm not saying that
all of it is but I'm saying it's the
same
it is it's it's the same
General problem that we're looking at
stuff that's going on all the time
relatively out in front of us that we
don't really are thinking about the way
that it's corrosive to society surely
child children having sex is not the
same thing as adult having sex that's
true truly that's surely true
okay so that's sort of contradictory to
what you just said no I'm talking about
I'm expanding the conversation with
something I don't know very much about
to something I have I had more
experience I think the question was do
you think this is something that we
should be worried about do you think the
top five issues way way more than JFK's
assassination way more way way I don't I
don't disagree I I absolutely agree I
think to me it's even more than top five
but uh I agree in that area how much you
think we're doing to protect these kids
how because how often do we hear about
people getting you know Cod how often do
you hear about you know it happened at a
massive scale there's a lot of people
that are getting away with this I don't
know I I didn't I'm not really an expert
and I didn't I didn't see the movie but
yeah it sounds terrible I mean and the
movie's get an enormous amount of
attention so it perhaps perhaps that's
that's the fulcrum that is needed to get
more done it is it is okay uh in regards
to education you know uh
a lot of the kids from LA and a lot of
the different districts from La have
reached out about you know what's going
on with their schools and the state of
California what books they're teaching
you know Rob if you can go to
valleytainment.com and type in the word
queer and go to the book uh if you can
I'd love to get his thoughts on this if
you go to valleytemen.com and then type
the word queer in search parents are
concerned about what's happening I'll
put it over here no no I'm concerned
about what's going on with what their
kids are being taught you and I I don't
know how old you are I think we're
closer I'm 50 it'll be 59 in September
you'll be 59
did he say 59 you're about to be 60. no
dude easy I'm gonna be 59 in September
you're going to 60 already oh I don't
know if you know 59 is right next to 60.
very nice okay very nice shocked I think
he's actually paying you a copy no no
he's there's no way I thought we're the
same age I'm 44. I thought you're like
in your late 40s okay so you know the
the the The Picture of Dorian Gray you
know that that story is 59 years old
yeah Dorian Gray from 50 Shades of Gray
The Picture of Dorian Gray it's it's
um it's this story about how this guy
continues to look really fit and
attractive his entire life but up in his
attic there's a portrait of him that is
decaying little by little by now and
it's it's about this this whole it's an
Oscar wild story it's all about this
whole idea that that we may look good
outside but we're actually we're
decaying wow
so here's here's a click on that if you
could go uh uh Anthony you say I'm left
but I'm not far left right there's
certain things you don't agree with
everything on the left so here's a
question for you they send me these
picture pictures
that 10 year old kids can now learn in
school uh here's a uh Sex book sex book
if you go a little lower teaching boys
how to give boys a [__] if you go a
little lower go a little lower right
there you know you had to give another
boy a blow job keep going lower do you
think it's appropriate for 10 year old
kids to have to read material like this
in schools I don't know anything about
this book uh I I just just logic I mean
you know let's just
assume all of these facts
uh no I would not I would not be crazy
about my son
um reading any of that because he's that
age well listen I appreciate you for
being uh straight up with that because
that's exactly what's going on in the
state of California so and and Newsome
uh came out with a video and he said I
can't even send you the clip on the
video it's like we are not going to let
them ban these books and they're doing
what happened in these different so
let's take a step back here let's take a
step back
we're a big country a lot of teachers a
lot of school districts we we in this
country in our form of government we
ostentatiously keep education decisions
close to home that they're well the
education budget's like four percent in
this in the federal government the
budget is the time because the things
that we're going to these determinations
we're going to make about schools we
understand a society we want to make
closer to home because they should
reflect the values of their community
not every community in every book and
every school board and every library is
going to do it exactly the way you and I
would but the 64 000 question or the
thirty thousand foot whatever metaphor
you want to use is we can use these
things to try to like poke at this idea
that the world's on fire and everything
is destroyed everything's wrong or we
can say listen that that classroom has a
group of parents that can go to the
principal and go to a school board the
last thing I want is someone like Rhonda
Santa saying that I am going to decide
or in Tallahassee that's what the
capitalist of the state yes or in
Tallahassee we are going to decide what
books parents or kids or teachers are
going to teach I don't believe
politicians are that smart I don't
believe their that their values are so
much better than the parents in in my my
district are and I I think that the
hardest thing for politicians to do is
say you know what I'm not the best
person to make this decision the best
person to make this decision is people
and you know what people are going to
make mistakes they're going to get
things wrong do I want my my son reading
that book no but I don't know what we
get at when we're trying to like you
know we're trying to make this
suggestion that we're going to turn this
that we are you're talking about a state
that is 3 000 miles away and you're
trying to draw some conclusion about
some horrible book it's not it's not in
a in one school it's in the parents or
state Anthony you're very well spoken
and you're very sharp on a lot of things
thank you and
no you are I appreciate it
you've spent a
good part of your adult life and debate
you're very very good at it but what you
just said I don't even think you believe
parents don't really have the ability
you look all over the United States you
have parents trying to go to school
boards so they could do this local as
you brought up they don't have the
ability to do that they have the ability
to appear but they don't they're not
being heard
the statement what's the evidence my
friend
the evidence what do you how many school
board meetings you want to pick where
parents come up and say I don't want my
kids to read this book I don't want my
kids you're going to have parents
showing up and other parents are going
to say different things this is an
imperfect thing you get your say in this
country you don't get your way and we
certainly shouldn't have a say on
California books helping about 3 000
miles away and why are we animated
around these things because we're
animated around the idea that media
relies on conflict um for those of you
listening I'm banging my fists together
conflict we love it so we show something
like this
that some parents are animated about the
concept of age-appropriate Education
everyone is
no parents no parent is standing up
saying I'm standing up in favor of
inappropriate look teachers they are
teaching of course because it's
necessary for this argument for you to
take that no no I'm going to play Clips
okay let's go to the greatest hits my
mom was a school teacher
my mom was a schoolteacher for 30
something years yeah I can tell you how
and I have been to so many school board
meetings is what I used to do I would go
out and come back from Washington or as
a city council and I'd go to community
meetings people fight about stuff these
are not easy issues they're not now that
if I were a parent and my school was
doing that I'd go to school with me I'd
be pissed off and then I think I'd
probably win that case and say we
shouldn't be teaching this but
not if you're a parent but if you're a
parent you show me some excerpt to
discuss whether it's California New York
this is not a California it's Anthony
that's when the United States
your 11 year old son was exposed to this
or a grown adult a grown man was texting
your 11 year old son what would you do
about it that's not the question we're
suggesting
taking an excerpt from a California book
that I do what would you do if someone
you found someone texting yourself I
just wait a minute let's stick with the
books for a second I just told you what
I would do if that book appeared in in
my son's teaching what would you do what
I would do I would go to the school
board I'd go to the administrator I'd
rally to other parents to go do it
because that's the way we make decisions
at that level about these things we
don't do it on podcasts from thousands
of miles away who are profiting from the
not this one in particular who are
profiting from conflict Fox News all day
is around finding these foibles
accelerating into giant things in our
country talking about woke this and woke
that and every poll shows we're more
divided than we've ever been all I'm
saying is that we make these decisions
in an imperfect way and I'm not hang on
hang on you were poking at Pat for
changing the subject you just went to
Media using conflict to make ad revenue
and that's her business model okay
you're correct about that but let's go
back here this is not a 3 000 mile away
issue there are school boards all across
all 50 states pick one where parents are
bringing this up but they're being told
no and they're being pressed no you
stated he's going to be there you've
stated that before and I said bring me
some evidence to that I've seen more in
the other direction I've seen no no no
and you say well I didn't see that I've
seen thousands of books that have
abandoned and removed from shelves and
libraries All Around by legislatures
getting over there I don't need us to
answer this question who do you think is
more equipped to make these decisions
for a local community the local
community school boards and the local
community administrators or legislators
a half a state away who don't even
represent that District who who would
you think I I think we've already
already said that we the people in the
school board but it's not happening but
what if that's the issue your judgment
the point about three thousand miles
away is you're making a judgment on
their ability to do their jobs I get it
maybe if I was doing this is my judgment
the book so they went to a school
district in Mississippi I might make
different decisions but I'm a Jew from
Brooklyn so I'm not going to do that
if the books are in the classroom that
means the parents have lost
and they're in their classrooms and yeah
yes there might be a book in a classroom
in Mississippi that I don't like I am a
guy from Brooklyn New York and and what
so maybe let's let the legislature do it
let's let the governor do it maybe we
should elect a president who wants to do
it I mean it's just you just remember
something you want this perfect
formulation of every decision being
exactly where Fox News wants it at all
times no shit's gonna get screwed up
sometimes
and I didn't say president I didn't say
legislature I know you keep I know you
keep going back Upstream
I'm narrowing the scope of conflict to
say this is this local area
of argument no I am to make the opposite
argument which I believe is being made
here you're saying with three thousand
miles away and we don't like a decision
being made in a School District in
California no no you're narrowing the
point very good counselor you're
narrowing the point down to 3 000 miles
away as if that's the only place that's
happening it's not the books are in in
classrooms all across the United States
over and over again and I keep trying to
make since we don't have a specific
example except the one that's been on
the screen I will make the general
argument that it's none of your business
it's none of your business your business
is your school district your business oh
the world is coming to an end because
California is all [__] up the other
way around it's none of your business
what I do with my kids you don't get to
teach my kids about certain issues like
this on lgbtq at certain age and if
that's great you want to talk about sex
and all this stuff
no I'm not powerless you're gonna make
decisions exactly I make decisions
exactly so so why I'm not doing anything
to you the concept of running for boards
you're 100 right we did a video talking
about what was a video title Brandon we
talk about parents you got to go run uh
for board and rather than complaining
about it or do something about it we're
forward but to say these types of issues
you're 59 years old 15 years older than
me in school when you were 12 years old
did anybody teach you how to give a
[__] I don't believe anyone taught me
how to give a [__] Patrick do you
think you needed to learn how to do that
at 10 or 12 years old I I have trouble
accessing that part of my memory I I
highly doubted you're a very sharp guy
so far I mean I was not a player at 12.
let me guarantee you sucking another
voices dangling is not a player I'm
asking you a question about what it was
to if that was something you needed to
learn at the age of 10 or 11 or 12. that
part is Magic Patrick
you I have an 11 year old ask me about
my 11 year old that I can answer easily
but the point is the fact that two
things one I agree with them when I
disagree with them the area I agree with
them is a follow-on
uh uh kudos to you for straight up
saying
no I don't support something like that
if that was the case kudos to you for
saying that now number two kudos to
forsane parents do something about it
they are and many of these districts
they are they're fighting and they're
they're doing their both directions yeah
they're fighting in both they're
fighting to stop book bands and they're
starting to finding stuff this is the
way it's been in America since the birth
of our country but but we weren't this
insane 20 years ago we were in this
let's let's pause it 30 years ago yes I
can give you Gallop let's research all
of this stuff let's let's pause on that
go ahead
I do believe that yes
cultural things change and that
conversations about homosexuality yeah
about transgender yeah about gay
marriage have changed enormous amount we
are a country of we are a progressive
country in all kinds of different ways
but we also should acknowledge that we
do have an echo chamber in this country
that loves stuff like this we have at
least one candidate for president who
one of his stock and trade things is
this amorphous word about taking wokism
out we do have a Marketplace that is
accelerating these conflicts Beyond
California beyond our neighborhood Town
Halls to be Echo chamber types of things
that we are here thousands of miles away
arguing about them there's a market for
this I don't believe it's a healthy
Market Patrick I don't and every week I
try to say to my audience okay listen
let's try to return to the place that we
can have conversations around things
like how we structure government how we
make decisions how we try to find our
values expressed in government in ways
that don't necessarily that and and I
can tell you the values in a school
board in Mississippi and the values of
the school board in Chelsea New York
might be different we we don't have to
treat that as a threat to our kids
period
yeah I want to pull up a couple articles
here for you but you know what before
doing that I just want to get to my last
Point here so
um you were very uh uh eloquent on the
way you defended Hillary Clinton on who
she was when it comes down to politics
are you still close to that family I'm
not okay so who do you think between the
two was a better politician you think
Bill's a better politician do you think
Hillary's about I don't think Hillary
was a particularly good politician okay
so she's a better strategist you would
say she's more uh strategic she is she
is a classic blooming where she's potted
kind of public officials yeah everything
that she has been given to do I watched
her you know as a as a rookie elected
official coming to New York and become
an amazing Senator I watched her at
Secretary of State be like just she
blooms where she's potted she would have
she knows government well she's smart as
a very very smart person but I can tell
you that that it's hard it I think it
was hard for her to get her sea legs
being the first woman candidate of a
major party I think it was hard for her
to get her sea legs in the in the in the
framing of Bill Clinton's wife I think
it was a lot of things or a lot of
challenge she faced that you and I would
not face on the camera do you think
she's a good person I do okay so uh uh
you know when we you know announced the
fact that we're interviewing you we we
kind of crowdsource with the audience
what questions do you want to ask and
then our researching will go and say hey
is there any credibility to this or not
and we don't waste our time so hey we're
having Anthony Weiner on great
so you have to ask him about uh frazzle
drip go look it up oh this video is a
deep fake not to any credibility to it
on what happened with you know Hillary
Clinton whom on all this stuff nope
we're not going to ask him about that
because I don't yet see a real Source a
lot of it was stuff that you know
conspiracy all the stuff that's being
said we're not going there yeah you need
to ask him about pizza gate because
that's exactly what's going on with kids
yeah no we're not going there that's not
something we're going to be asking about
yeah you need to ask him about this and
you need to ask him about this I said
okay all of these things that they said
we have to ask you about to be fair it's
Bill Clinton officiated your wedding
with Huma your wife if I'm not mistaken
so you've been very close and your wife
is it still wife or is it ex-wife I
think it's separated since 2017 right
we're separated we we co-parent Jordan
but we're separated okay and you know
she was a right-hand person to Hillary
Clinton in 2016 while the Scandal was
taking place years before that she was
with Hillary for she's 25 20 years and
and the whole thing with the life
insurance you know the the email 650 000
the one folder with award life insurance
and the files that are in there so the
next thing that that people said you got
to ask him is the following so you know
Rob if he can pull up this story I'm
like I'm not gonna buy into this one
well nine out of 12 cops NYPD who saw
the email and saw what was in that
laptop you know committed suicide and it
was you know seven of them since June
and it was the most ever that this took
place and these are the men that
committed suicide so then we went and
looked it up and we're like no they did
commit suicide but it wasn't linked
directly to seeing the laptop or the
Intel there no problem so again no
credibility there so there's no reason
to ask you the question about the nine
out of 12 cops that side and they
wouldn't be listing them and give it
auction no my job is to listen because I
like to really listen we shouldn't be
listing these things these things it is
what it is destructive people actually
theories these are conspiracy theories
books about them though right but the
one thing that that we did look up that
wasn't a conspiracy theory was the final
one
and this is the one that's kind of weird
and and first thing I ask myself is how
the hell uh is our our guy here Anthony
Weiner still alive what do you mean by
that well when you go through the list
of people that have been close to
Hillary Clinton and the clintons and the
Deadpool this is not a conspiracy you
got the names of James McDougall okay
Clinton's convicted Whitewater partner
died of an apparent heart attack you
know Mary Mahoney a former White House
intern was murdered July 1997 at a
Starbucks coffee shop in Georgia John
Brown he died in a plane crash Vince
Foster Vince Foster was the next one he
by the way the James Dougal was a key
witness and a key Ken star investigation
he was in a plane crash why is he on the
list Ron Brown is another one but there
was a close person to this Victor razor
you got Paul Tooley Ed woolly you're
reading a list of people that Bill and
Hillary Clinton asking you they're
eating they're seven wait a minute I'm
asking you this question I'm asking you
this question and an answer at the end
so you got Jerry Parks James
Florence Martin Susan Coleman Paula
grober Danny casolero Paulo wilker
Johnny Walker Barbara wise we should
verify this yourself because you're
running a radio she should look it up I
don't know Dr Stanley heard Barry Beale
Barry seal Johnny
Kevin Ivey Dan Henry Keith Coney and
these were a part of the ivy Henry case
Keith mccaskill uh you can look it up
Ivy Henry case so Gregory Collins Jeff
Rhodes James Mill and Richard winter and
then you got the close bodyguards major
William Barclay Captain Scott Reynolds
Brian Hanley Tim Sable General
Williamsburg Robert Kelly Colonel Gary
Rhodes Steve Wells Robert Williams
Conway Le blue Todd McKean I'm done it's
40 six names and of what can you read me
the list when you read me the URLs
when I finish this when I finished this
still in the storm.com you can look it
up still in the storm.com you can look
at a big moment guys yeah so you you can
go by the way ads about Chemtrails at
the end of it he hasn't even asked the
question but he was just reading the
article he's reading oh he's reading a
list of names so he hasn't even asked
the question it's a list the fact that
you're getting nervous is an answer it's
not nervous I just this stuff let me
wrap it when you read exactly it makes
us sick as well it also it actually
doesn't it obviously because the
establishment that's the question by
reading a list of will your reaction as
an answer conspiracy I know these things
make me sick and people are wrong
someone went into a pizza poll in
Washington because they believe this
[__] and you're making an Echo chain
reaction is an answer so let me go to it
here now no no no no no no no no no no
no
my reaction is my reaction can you tell
me what that list in your view you
haven't allowed me to finish
and these people who you don't even know
who they are you're reading them on a
list of something making some kind of
increment as if it's somehow suspicious
you don't know who these human beings
are who are families who are like out
there and now you're spending at least
two hours with you one by one by one
explaining questions individuals are if
you want to do that how about you pick
one pick one and tell me who he was and
what his story was uh no no not you
you're asking me the question pick one
name and then tell me pull up Vince
Foster if you want no Vince Foster that
suicide has been investigated 50 times
one of the Obscure names why did you put
Ron Brown here let me read Ron Brown Ron
Brown a Commerce Secretary who a plane
crash while he was on a humanitarian
Mission crashed inside of a mountain so
what do you want to know about Ron Brown
pick a name I'm gonna ask you a question
and there are some of those people that
had military titles in front of them
you're dragging their names you should
be ashamed because your families would
want to know if your families would want
to know some conspiracy theory podcast
uh some seriously theory that nine
people read you find some guy that comes
out and then you go you go from Ron
Brown to some obscure officer that used
to protect Bill Clinton who passed away
may he baby may he rest in peace for his
service and you are dragging them into
some black conspiracy therapies may all
of them Rest In Peace So here's the
question for you because millions of
people are not convinced Hillary Clinton
again with the other people including
myself if you want to do that
don't try to make it about some Bozo and
put up a website put in your own words
here's a question for you guy it's a
very simple question for you so how is
it when you think about other candidates
okay
everybody has a stereotype you have a
reputation whether you like it or not
what's your reputation your reputation
as you like to text underage girls and
you like to talk to girls and use sex
sending pictures of your dangling that's
your reputation whatever you do you
can't do anything about it Adam has a
reputation Adam is a Playboy in Miami
I'm getting back to it Tom's got a
reputation his reputation is a man who
and right now your reputation is lifting
strangers who served in the military and
dragging their names they have a
reputation to ask tough questions and
put some people like you off that's my
recording dead people who want me to
stand up for it oh trust me we are
standing up for them more than you are
standing up for them let's see you
better get back to that list because
we're going to clear some people's names
today my question for you is my question
for you is how is it
that in the last 50 years
we don't have a single candidate
everybody has their own hey John F K was
a Playboy with Marilyn Monroe Trump
Karen McDougall Stormy Daniels you know
George Bush linked to 911 and weapons of
mass destruction Bill Clinton linked to
Arkansas women all this others everybody
has a reputation how is it
that the reputation that follows them is
people close to them die
why is that a story that people many
people believe in why are the clintons
in their 70s yet
if I you don't think I can make a list
of other people who are 70 something
years old and say this person
hold on how come they haven't done that
she's in the same thing I have no
freaking idea
but so are you saying so you agree with
what I'm saying that with Reagan so how
come there but none that would care what
are you making about these men and women
who uses so many people close to them
die how is it so many people close to
everybody dies are you suggesting okay
I'm asking the question you're asking a
bizarre question exactly
did people die no what pisses me off and
I'm going to say this again because you
apparently are not listening to me you
had a list of people off an obscure
website that that that is that of of
conspiracy theory taking a Venn diagram
of everyone that ever worked in the
orbit of someone who served in public
life for 50 years and you listed them
including people in the military
including strangers you could not pull
out of and you are implying that there's
something to say here let me finish my
thoughts let me finish my thoughts
please do so because I got another let
me finish my thing I'm here for you
you're implying both with the question
and with the website the website says it
explicitly you're implying it let me
finish go ahead you're implying that
something's done until he's done
go for it you are implying that
something nefarious is a foot both with
the question and with the list
Hillary Clinton she's a big girl I'm a
big boy you're a big boy the people that
you just listed they're all listen to me
no these are obscure people that you
could not pull out every politician
buddy wait a whole life fantastic you
know what you are you are you are the
classical you list someone's name are
you gonna go back everybody
you know that ad hominem attack on me
yeah he's gonna somehow clear that
person's name there's anybody at this
table that's a bigger believer I tell
you oh yeah you you just listed some
stranger
way opinion good look for you you're
reading something for you're reading a a
conspiracy website it's for you some
people say yeah some people
saying to you Wikipedia conspiracy
website you want it no no no you want to
take a run with me
conspiracy theory right at the top
conspiracy theory how come Reagan
doesn't have this conspiracy theory oh
wait a minute
oh wow really why do they though some of
the stereotypes are true like you have
some reputation it's true some of it
some of the stuff they say about other
people it's not a stereotype that's a
made-up story about strangers how come
others don't have that made-up story
people have it all the time look at the
internet give me another body count with
another president or candidate do you
really think that someone offenders do
me a favor do you really think Barack
Obama body count do you really think oh
you always go why did you go to Barack
Obama not born in this country by the
way where was that podcast did you guys
do that one no that's never anything oh
why oh come on so people say it
there's there's a Wikipedia thing on it
huh these people are strangers that you
just read a list of and I think out of
deference to them
settle down no no no you're pretty hard
to take the angle you did listen to me
if talking to us yeah oh okay you should
cut that list out of those sure we can
still have the argument you and I are
big boys cut that list I'm not going to
be cutting that list because the world
that's right here's what everybody is in
the world needs that poor person's
family that you can't even make exactly
that no some people say what does it
matter now there's some people say what
does it matter now some people say you
play that famous podcast people say play
that clip again what does it matter now
what does it matter these people what
does it means the subject all you want
anyone who read that list they're still
waiting for you to come back you realize
why some people apologize to those
realize why some people you should
apologize to those people why do you
keep saying that because you apologize
about listing those people on some
obscure website as if something about
their death was shrouded in some kind of
a mystery dishonors their memory now if
you are Hillary Clinton if you are
Hillary Clinton or Anthony Weiner that
may sound fine if you are something if
you are some person who has one of these
jackasses on the internet showing up at
their doorstep saying tell me about the
death of your father how did Hillary
Clinton we had someone walk into a
pizzeria in Washington with a gun
because I've heard that phrase before by
other people Play it Again Play it again
I've heard this phrase watch the whole
Benghazi Let's Go the whole Benghazi no
it's the phrase the fact is we had four
different Americans was because of a
protest or was it because of guys
difference
from the 10 second Mark yeah yeah play
it from the one second Mark so we really
get contact right there go play it right
from the one tenth of the second
Americans what difference at this point
does it make that's what you said let's
let's hear it what a script you're
duplicating it very it's here you're
duplicating this like you disagree with
her point of course I do you do of
course it matters whether it was a
protest that came from
Libya to the to that family you know to
that family and by the way do you know
do you know why she cleaned the
Republicans clock in that hearing
because she talked about how many times
she ain't a president guy that's
cleaning the clock the American people
cleaned her clothes
why do you think she's not a president
hearing the American people clip and
then
so going back to it here's here's what
you're doing right now which is
fantastic you just influence a lot of
people to you just influence a lot oh
you can find you can find other words
for yourself no I saw what you did by
listing the the conspiracy theories
you're not going to ask about about
those things sorry that was dishonorable
that's which part is the soundable the
list of conspiracy theory you know is
[__] but still putting it out there
this thing this thing there's a lot of
uh I think abilities
it's not true look at what you had a
site cite any any media that you would
ever read in your day-to-day life for
that go call one of those people I want
to answer questions no you make a point
I'll respond to it and one of your
producers call up one of those families
and tell them if they want to be listed
in one of these conspiracy podcasts
you're so you're so sweet for saying
that this you're so sweet for playing
this deceptive game I got to tell you
from watching you for the last time uh I
got to tell you I know this is not what
you're used to doing man I'm sorry I
actually it's funny I texted with
somebody should I give them what they're
used to or should I whatever and they
said just whatever you know how I know
who you were the moment you walked here
you know how I knew who you know because
I disagree with you let me tell you we
have too much of this I don't know let
me tell you who you are guys here's who
you are this is good media you're
getting good content this is this is who
you are you walk up here and you said
what's your name I'm sorry I I I should
I should have done no no no no no you
said what's your name and then you say I
call my friends to say should I give
these guys this you know the name you
know the show but no no no no if you use
your whole first name okay so it's like
I apologize what's your name I apologize
above everybody I apologize
and I was willing to give you a fair
share you walked off as an [__] I
apologize I apologize I didn't know if
you used the shortened version of your
name I should have researched that
listen I want to say that you said
what's your name I know but to see if
you would give me a hints
you said what's your name I said Patrick
then you asked do you prefer Pat or
Patrick if you know my name is Patrick
you would have eliminated one of the
questions and you would ask so the point
is and by the way we're helping you to
identify yourself
as a male as a father as an entrepreneur
I apologize go back to your question I
apologize you do you accept my amends
from I apologize sure I respect I
apologize but the point I'm making to
you is if you come in like that and I'm
asking you a question you'll react
you're reading too much into it you're
reading too much I apologize for that
that was socially wrong with me to do I
was trying to learn whether you go by
Pat or Patrick I apologize I could have
asked one of your man I could have asked
people I apologize for Anthony and I
hope you accept my amends for that when
you did show up this isn't a name call
you were kind of douchey at the first
five minutes I got some bad news as I
walked on stage yeah okay well I got
some bad news
you want to see what it is maybe you
guys can help me with it no I'm gonna
make my point and then you say your bad
news I also had bad news today I mean
I'm sorry
just because you had bad news doesn't
need you to be a douchebag when you walk
on a stage I don't think I was a dude
you're talking about the floods you're
talking about I don't know who you guys
are making sure you're asking Patrick
his name is on the freaking show it was
pretty douchey dude no and we have
people don't disagree with more than
we're going back to the Patrick pad
thing I apologize for that I make amends
for that the thing about the pond it was
a serious thing why I asked him about
this landlord it was I was actually he's
the freaking landlord dog
oh you're being funny of course somebody
I didn't know I'm sorry the moment I
felt your your that guy I had to give it
back to you of course I had no idea
you're like the landlord sucks here
what's going on
he's the freaking landlord let's let the
audience in on this there's a big flood
outside it just rained I'm unfamiliar
with that kind of torrential thing you
don't know anything and you're just like
this sucks this sucks this sucks what's
your name that's not how you start a
conversation let's hear him out okay
first of all I have made amends for the
Patrick thing and and I should have done
it I should have done it sooner it was
not any sign of disrespect I just didn't
know if it was Pat or Patrick I get that
a lot people will sometimes say Anthony
or Tony and I said I just said Anthony I
I didn't mean it to be that way as far
as the small talk the awkwardness I I I
apologize I'm a radio guy who was
brought up in a time of of media and
social media that didn't have a lot of
this as a politician so I assumed I
thought we were in I thought we're doing
a podcast so I was disoriented by some
of this combined with the fact I got
some bad news just before I got on the
air I apologize I make Amendment and I
don't mind telling you that I am out of
practice of this kind of three-on-one
you know I'm fine doing it it Harkens
back to a time when I would do this for
a living and I didn't think it was that
great to watch but when it comes to the
things
Anthony just to be clear we strategized
before this what conversations they want
to have under no circumstances was this
a gang up on no no often times I agree
with you no they don't agree with you I
was referring to that Dynamic but what
triggered me about that I'm going to try
to say comic because I feel like I was
yelling which was my intention
what triggered me about that is that I
don't think sometimes people fully
appreciate
that these
crazy out there theories that give
people who need to find a narrative to
explain the Unexplained in their lives
to give them some comfort have real harm
it causes in the world when I have to
get a security detail to walk with my
son to school and my and my my wife has
to be concerned about being pushed on a
subway track they have real costs and so
when real people substantial peoples
people with real platforms like the
people in this room
stand up and and elevate it even to
elevate it to say we're not going to
talk about it elevated and then read
from one of these websites a list of
names I don't know who those people are
I do know who the police officers and
other conspiracy theories I do know the
harm it does to their families who are
dealing with uh with a suicide to get
called to have crazy people coming off
the streets because they want to prove
something ask about me ask about my
laptop ask about Hunter Biden ask about
my experience with the criminal justice
ask about being in prison ask about
Hillary Clinton we're big we're big boys
and girls you want to put Ron Brown on a
case of that though Clinton's murdered
someone who had a tragic plane crash and
there's a that he he was such a renowned
person as a building named after him
across the United Nations that's fine
these individuals who get caught up in
these bizarre webs deserve better and
they deserve someone to stand up and say
enough and it shouldn't be this is a
real you guys are a big deal you're five
million whatever we're saying enough
enough with the establishment okay but
you could have done that through out
reading that list of course I had to
read the name because in that case let's
go Name by name so we can clear their
names of course I could listen and by
the way the reason why you know by the
way let me let me speak one final Point
there's nothing wrong with saying you
know what that's true I could have done
the story without reading that list of
random people I couldn't have done it
without it and I'm a guy that's very
comfortable and go back to them then if
you think it made a point then let's go
back to the list of names here one by
one you can tell me what you think that
person did here's here I'm a person just
so you know who doesn't believe this
stuff just so you know I don't believe
this but a lot of people do that does
not mean it's something you should
Elevate but a lot of people don't
believe the moon landing him and if
you're gonna have it so why can't you
have that conversation have a
conversation a lot of people believe in
Flat Earth a lot of people believe that
Barack Obama wasn't born in this country
here's the distinction I believe that
Obama was born here's the distinction I
made that doesn't mean you can't have
that conversation I'm not saying I have
I once said you're gonna have a
conversation yes you didn't want to even
read the list no the list is not the
conversation of course it's quite a
different thing to say that we that we
believe that there is a place that
skinning babies in the basement and not
say here's the name of the Pizzeria and
the guy that owns it in his address do
you see that distinction
do you of course you do because it's
being responsible it's a you can have a
conversation about a crazy Conspiracy
Theory without listening some poor
stranger's name on a list of 45 names
go tell that to Google to not put it on
no no no you have a responsibility
higher than Google you don't take
everything you read on Google put it on
your air okay let me ask you a question
so right so so MSNBC CNN the way you're
like Fox News this fox knows that how
many stories has CNN and MSNBC said that
ended up not being true the last five
six years how many of them God knows a
ton of them right so I know what are we
going to do we're going to go out there
and do this
for people to watch your stories I'm
sure stories are untrue but let's not
change let me let's not change the
victim here the victim here is not the
world the victim is that individual why
am I doing it this is this is why are
you gonna go back and watch your
documentary people didn't do anything
you know what time I watch your
documentary last night
that's all I ask edit out the listing
time I watch your documentary last night
we wrapped up here what time did we wrap
up here 11 30 12 o'clock I go to the
house I watch your documentary did you
enjoy it I mean people say five minutes
and no joke an hour and 35 minutes went
in five minutes everybody has to watch a
documentary so and I'm telling you right
now to really understand who he is
because the way the exchange the him and
his wife the Dynamics right after this
they're running around it's a very hour
and 35 feels like five minutes okay
that's why I said he's a great
campaigner I can give credit to that
he's a hustler he's a worker he's going
out there rattling challenging fighting
he's a fighter right forget about all
the other stuff there's a good things
that we can learn from it my entire
question was the following question how
the hell is Anthony Weiner uh still
alive because
you know the whole uh uh what is that
word a a a dead man switch is that what
it's called a dead man switch how you
know this guy has so much information on
them
what are you buying into I think Anthony
I think if there's I think if there's 10
people in America
that have the most dirt on the clintons
I think you're on that list
they're the most exam moment people even
people are making up stuff there's so
much they're the most examined people on
Earth what do you call them honorable
you'd call them honorable you'd call
them honest yeah I do okay great so
guess what those who agree with you I
know but but here's the but let me I'm
gonna this whole idea people say okay
you're too smart for people say you have
amazing opinions you articulate them
very well you don't need to go back to
this uncomfortable I understand but
Patrick let me just Patrick let me just
to get to my point you don't need people
on crazy websites say you don't say why
does Wikipedia say you don't say why is
this you can State your own opinion if
you believe something I can have a
conversation with you about it but
there's all kinds of things that are
wrong that are that are not on the level
that are dishonorable that are dangerous
and that are harmful to regular people
not you the four of us we're gonna be
fine Hillary Clinton's gonna be fine
Bill Clinton's gonna be fine our friends
that work for Bill they're going to be
fine but these people who are Anonymous
people that get caught up in this or
even worse crazy people that show up on
doorsteps of people
because they believe stuff that gets
elevated we have to just because it's
out there doesn't mean we have to
elevate it that's all I'm saying to dirt
what dirt do you imagine that I have I
mean ask me anything I'm here ask me
anything I think you I
I think you are so protected by by
watching protected I was literally sent
to prison for for sexting yeah how
protected am I I think and I don't think
you would consider me protected when I
was in the can either pal what do you
mean protect it no my life was destroyed
where's that where was the Deep State
when I [__] needed them dude let me
tell you you're you're truly a flag
carrier to them and it's very hard to
find people like you I told you I'm not
close with them anymore I was I'm
ostracized for them because they loved
home of I wasn't I married into this
relationship I respect the quality of
loyalty and you're super loyal to the
clintons I just want to demystify for
people who think there's some giant
cabal around everything that you know
what sometimes [__] just happens
sometimes people just you know they they
this and try to find narratives around
everything I mean I have a laptop at
home
go Google Anthony go Google or look on
Twitter Anthony Weiner's laptop and look
how many wackadoodle for follower
crazies in the middle of nowhere who
believe [__] about that laptop so you
know what with the Trump administration
had that laptop
yeah the Trump Administration they're
protecting Hillary Clinton they released
the contents of that laptop so do you
know out of those 46 uh people who I
mentioned earlier I trust most of them
uh probably of course voted for uh uh uh
what do you call it Clinton's and I
trust most of their families the people
about Anthony weiners let me no no relax
oh I'm sorry let me finish just pay
attention we got nine more minutes we're
done and you can text anybody I'm just
dealing with nothing you got to get off
texting sometimes so for me when I think
about those 46 names okay
and I ask myself they're probably
supporters of Clinton's and they're
probably supporters of what they stood
for and probably even their families but
this whole thing started off with a
couple different things I asked you a
question about RFK it took a half a
second to realize he doesn't have your
vote you can't you don't even like the
guy I got the feeling I didn't I give a
pretty punch yeah totally fine and you
were straight up about it which I
respect you didn't hold back
but to me
would start to happen is the following
when you go back years ago and say an
emperor or the establishment had
somebody that went up against the
establishment Emperor or the leader like
let's just say some powerful people they
had to kill him off they had to give all
kill all their sons off because
eventually someone's going to seek
Vengeance and that Vengeance may take a
decade two decades three decades four
decades five decades I think RFK is the
complete opposite of a person that says
what difference does that make and he
wants to find out if the establishment
is a real thing and how much power they
get I hear you that's all it is I hear
you and I know that some people say
thing it's I get that
this notion of establishment is the
hobgoblin of little Minds we are a
country of millions of very people that
all come from different places that are
very divided and the people that go into
government
are are come from all different places
sometimes they're politically appointed
usually they're not and this notion of
an establishment if there's so many
instances if there was an establishment
that things would have gone very
differently we want to blame someone we
want an explanation we every life does
not give you Patrick narratives that are
also tight sometimes people just
disagree on stuff some people sometimes
people just are wrong about yeah totally
fine so like this whole idea that
everything has to be some kind of a
conspiracy or an establishment there's
no establishment out there it's just a
bunch of people it's just a who give me
a name of someone who's in The
Establishment today I'm I'm in America
Mitch McConnell you're the establishment
you're a five million dollar five
million um
eyeballs
who's the biggest cable company in
America Fox because there's only one of
them yeah there's only one of them 99 of
everybody no absolutely not of course
they are by the way they're a giant
multinational corporation with the most
watched teams let me restate that let me
restate that Rupert Murdoch's not
established let me restate that yes I
don't disagree okay so Rupert Murdoch
did everything he could to stop Hillary
Clinton so then you have two members of
The Establishment so who's the
establishment in that case oh no no two
sides of the same no guys so I'm sitting
so far
for the longest time and Hillary no no
he was working for trump it would have
been Jeb Bush and Hillary this who would
have been establishment that's the
establishment correct okay Kennedy's
warrant The Establishment they're the
anti-establishment I know but you're
picking names and saying this is
bushes the clintons
is Fox News what the establishment is
Rupert Murdock The Establishment I think
if he supports the establishments
obviously
ask a question obviously establishment
he supports the establishment he is a
talking kid for the establishment
likes Trump
I don't care likes doesn't like this
doesn't like Murdoch likes Trump you're
saying the establishment is so powerful
and I'm pointing out the single biggest
media organ in the country is an
establishment thanks okay so yes if
that's your definition of establishment
yeah establish is YouTube an
establishment The Establishment yeah the
YouTube at the top is because this I
don't know YouTube has this and it has
the crazy kid and it has my third 30
people watching me end up on a stream
yeah so I think it's going to go up
after this one
really congrats you you're gonna get
you're gonna get because we're gonna put
the link to your show and if people
heard this they're gonna go watch your
show Rob I guarantee you get more
subscribe
to your biggest show I guarantee you to
be your biggest you're on all right put
it
no we don't have I was gonna tell I
wanted to talk to you off camera about
this like the different ways these
things work we don't really ha our guys
our listeners are not giant I mean I do
I we put it out in the Fargo podcast our
guys will find you what's the name of
your podcast on YouTube just just do the
no no no I'm not on uh just do wnbc
you're not on YouTube no he's not really
not really what no but I'll explain dude
you're on AM radio you're dealing with
Dinosaurs Anthony you gotta pivot but
you know the whole point is what do we
want people to watch me on if you're
selling ad space on a radio station you
don't want to draw people to YouTube
yeah you guys you guys are in 2029 I'm
in and I'm still dealing with 1985. by
the way that's the problem I'll give you
feedback
I would love to I would love to have
five million on uh yeah we may not agree
on a lot okay uh we may not agree on a
lot and your choice of lifestyle is
different than the way I live but let's
I consider that a shot I mean don't
don't don't I don't think any of us
should be judged any of us should be
judged that way I haven't looked at your
phone I'm not like whatever it is
I have come clean about about a private
thing you know about me that is
embarrassing you're not gonna let me
finish my point but that's the third
time you've done that little kind of
thing by the way I can tell you 40 times
when in the middle of me asking a
question you interrupted me for the
entire time I was trying to finish my
you asked some wrong questions you got
to admit well that's you can say that
after I'm done asking a question but
here's what I was going to say to you uh
uh watching you take all the other stuff
away you don't belong on radio
you do not you do not belong on radio
You Belong with a camera you don't
belong on radio so I don't know what
you're a different kind of show you got
to listen to my show it's not this tone
it's not like this it's very
conversating like I take callers they
yell at me a little bit I'm friendly
like this thing it was actually paying
you a call you guys are going to walk
away you guys are going to walk away and
say we know that was a jackass I'm gonna
walk away and say listen that was kind
of it was interesting like I haven't
done that in a while we're not going to
say this we're going to say this was an
interesting conversation but here's but
here's here's what I say I am fascinated
by I mean I was asking a question not to
be not to like oh my God I'm so much
smarter Anthony I really I want to
understand all of this take a guess how
many people are watching live right now
take a guess just live not total views
because this will get millions of views
800 I mean it's over a thousand take a
guess give me a number like we're
watching nine o'clock on a
no do you don't give them that number
right now 15 000 people are watching
live
but that's not a number that is pretty
average for us who would be like a
stream that like oh Tyson must have
gotten a ton right well but you're doing
great am I doing okay here's the part
for you to know just in the last two
hours of being alive how this is
concurrent we're at fifteen thousand the
last two hours two hours
it's 47 000 people wow that's by the end
of the day it's going to be 300 000
people that's that's my entire that's my
entire show yeah so anyways uh welcome
to the non-mastery media Anthony welcome
to non-establishment uh TV baby what
it's worth for what it's worth the one
part I have to tell you okay you got
more brass than a lot of these other
guys that are running for office who
will not come and have a conversation
with podcasts like this on a long form
and you did it we don't have to agree
with everything I can absolutely respect
the fact that you're willing to come out
here and have this conversation and
hopefully if we ever do this again next
time we don't need to go through this
type of a conversation we can talk more
issues and the next one could be a lot
more friendlier please invite me back
and maybe I'll get you do you ever do a
radio show I'll go put you on if we
invited
this was this this this you know when my
son was away at camp I I made this pact
I'm going to say yes to things that
otherwise I had not been I don't know
who I was dealing with so I've been
saying no no no I finally said yeah and
I I don't have a regret doing it I am
probably going to look at this and say
Jesus you're not you're out of practice
you're getting too hot you're you're
getting it get under your skin a little
bit too much
etc etc maybe let the thing breathe a
little more I would probably have notes
like that but I would say and I would
have this conversation with Nancy Pelosi
all the time when I would go on Fox News
she would say why do you go on there
you're just giving oxygen to the enemy
and I'm saying they're not the enemy
they're the opposition and who knows who
among their troops might someday be
fighting for us and if I assume that I'm
going to get one percent of that crowd
that's thousands and thousands of people
I I you have no idea how much I respect
that and unfortunately the the part
about like the criticism we get okay let
me tell you what criticism I got
yesterday when we posted that you're
going to be on you if you could just see
my phone on who texted me last night on
how annoyed they were with us to have
you on you would you would you would be
blown away who texted saying I can't
believe that guy's going to be on vice
versa if we have somebody from the other
side saying I can't believe he's having
them on but the part that we have
everybody feels comfortable coming here
having a conversations with us and I
can't wait to talk to Como this Saturday
uh uh and also so for everybody that's
watching a couple things we're going to
put the link to His Radio Show below
it's also the Twitter account where I
put both of them as well so people can
go I'll follow and and watch what he's
got going on uh tonight we have another
live podcast here holy moly this is a
crazy day what time is the podcast
tonight by the way 7 P.M 7 to 9 p.m
tonight with 200 people in attendance
and then we'll go to the Cigar Lounge
afterwards Dave Smith will be here we
have a video we're going to be releasing
tonight
that a four-star general
talks about the north stream pipeline
on what happened with it that a how do I
Define this properly and and Insider
send this video to us and we may we may
drop that video tonight on who he thinks
was behind Nordstrom and let me tell you
I think a lot of people are going to
lose their mind so we'll be on again
tonight and aside from that some of you
guys I keep asking Pat I want to go to
the next one vivex town hall is going to
be
August 4th here uh uh if you want to get
a ticket there text award 3103 text
award podcast to
310-340-1132 again text the word podcast
to
310-340-1132 cannot wait to see you guys
here we got a few more tickets on the
general and I think some premium seats
available for the town hall take care
everybody Anthony once again thanks for
coming up Sir take care everyone bye-bye
[Music]